this multi-generational family business
is the driving force behind the iconic
motorcycle jacket i sat down with chief
operating officer Jason shot of shot NYC
at the company's factory where the means
of production are as timeless as the
jackets themselves so this is what the
leather looks like when it lands on
Jon's table that's right Jason shot is
the chief operating officer of shot NYC
so what kind of leather is this what is
this so this is a naked cowhide from
hand cut leather to the signature star
these unique trademarks have caught the
attention of several stars themselves
we've been as amazed as everyone else
the way our jackets go out and live a
full life and sometimes they end up on
the backs of some incredible people like
Marlon Brando in the wild one in 1953
the movie comes out and you've got these
bad guys wearing jackets they banned
them from schools there was a lot of
concern around the family that was gonna
put a dent into production but sales
just balloon why are you trying to be so
rude I don't like cups introducing
American culture to this new template of
cool was a byproduct of co-founders Jack
and Irving shot original business
venture in 1913 they started a business
in the Lower East Side of New York and
they were making fur line raincoats
which I guess there must have been a big
market for a fur-lined I was gonna say I
don't know in the late 1920s shot was
the first to marry a leather jacket with
a zipper
creating an icon the motorcycle jacket
with the shot family name not big enough
to brand Erving named his new must-have
creation after his favorite brand of
cigar the perfecto there's such a
visceral reaction when you see the
jacket you know it really does have
transformative powers I've seen people
put a perfecto jacket on and they just
they turn into a badass before shot
created a symbol of rebellion known to
grace the back of musicians and actors
the company supplied those representing
the epitome of order you've been
supplying to the military for many many
years going back to before World War two
we've made the sheepskin jackets bomber
jackets pea coats parkas we've made
police jackets for many different police
departments including the New York NYPD
and all of that is collective knowledge
that we apply into many of the jackets
we produce we're so busy focusing on on
the factory it's not just about function
and fashion for this clothing company
for us it's more important to stay true
to our heritage where we do best is
focusing on telling that story in our
production telling a story of Americana
through the styles we create rather than
focusing on what people are doing on
runways we're looking into our past and
that's where we get our inspiration
shots designs are timeless and so are
some of their production methods I've
always imagined that my perfecto was
made on the same machine that Brando's
and everybody else who wore their perfec
toes was made on we are using a lot of
the same machinery that we used from
those early days of in the 50s and even
before
if it ain't broke don't fix it keeping
the company domestic comes with a high
price tag but the tag the shot family
values most is the one sewn into every
jacket made in the USA I wouldn't want
to disappoint my great-grandfather and
my grandfather and be the one to take it
offshore I couldn't even imagine doing
that how do you think Jack and Irving
shot would feel about the company today
I think that they would be proud my
great-grandfather was very proud of
starting this company and he'd be very
proud to be here now it's up to the next
generation to keep this family affair up
and running you're the fourth generation
to run the company you have kids
are they the future I've shot I feel
very confident that there will be fifth
generation of family members that have
an interest in joining the business
because it's such a great place to work
I'd love coming to work and producing
something you know I love the fact that
every day there's hundreds of jackets
that are rolling off the production
floor and you can look at it and and get
such a sense of pride